Speaker 1: So Republican Texas Senator Ted Cruz
continues to say almost downright sinister things
about gun safety. Most recently saying
that if there were no guns in America,
the number of murders would actually go
up. Huh? How is that possible? We'll talk
about it. Here is the clip. Ted Cruz
on his I guess he has a podcast now
called Verdict. It's a very weird and deranged
program. But let's listen to what Ted Cruz had
to say. See if you can make sense out of this.
Speaker 4: Taking away every firearm that
Michael Knowles owns would not have stopped this
psychopath from murdering children in Uvalde.
And by the way, we see that in Chicago
and New York and D.C. and California,
where they have very strict gun control, you know,
and the criminals still have guns and still carry
out murders. If you could wave a magic wand and
eliminate all firearms in America. There would be
substantially more murders than there are today.
Speaker 1: That is an absolutely nutty comment.
If you could wave a magic wand and eliminate all
firearms in America. There would be substantially
more murders. Think about it on an incident by
incident basis. Imagine this particular shooter
in Texas. The shooter maybe would have killed
someone. But the odds are that without a gun,
he doesn't kill nearly as many people. I've
never heard of an incident. To go back to
our earlier Good Liar segment where
someone kills 20 people with a hammer.
I've never heard of an incident in which police,
armed police, I assume in Ted Cruz's vision,
the police still have firearms where armed police
don't go in to confront a knife wielding attacker
for 80 minutes because they're afraid. I've
just never heard of that. Now, remember,
we're doing imaginary stuff. If you could wave a
wand, and if waving the wand actually eliminated
all the firearms, how on earth would there be
more murders? It is a logical impossibility.
Now, it's also remember important to remember that
the rate of firearm homicides per 100,000 people
is off the charts in the United States. So you
look at what we've we're putting this up. This is
from the I mean, in the U.S., the rate of firearm
homicides per 100,000 people is just over four.
You then have Chile just under two and then
a whole bunch of countries at either 0.5
or lower. You know, a lot of these places, Spain
is 0.13 firearm homicides per 100,000 people.
The U.K., which has very strict gun control. 0.04
firearm homicides per 100,000 people. The major
difference is we have the most guns. Now, do a lot
of these countries have better access to mental
health care? Yes, many of them do. Do do many of
these countries not have the toxic and depraved
American gold gun culture? Yes, many of them
don't have that. But the biggest difference
is the number of firearms in the civilian
population per capita. And you see the outcome
of that in the rate of firearms homicides. And
the major difference is we have the most guns.
Apply Ted Cruz's logic to almost everything
else. Well, if you eliminated all cars, you
would end up with more traffic fatalities. We'll
hold on. How how would that work? That doesn't
make any sense. Maybe if you eliminated all cars,
you'd end up with, I don't know, more deaths from
heart attack because there'd be no vehicles to
take people to emergency rooms. Oh, okay. Well,
that's plausible. And we could explore whether
it's true. And much the same way if you waved a
magic wand and eliminated all guns, maybe the
number of murders from other things would go
up. But relative to the number of murders that can
so easily be done with high powered firearms, the
number of murders would certainly go down. And at
this point, they're just they're not even thinking
realistically in any way. They're just
they're just not it's just not it's not
we're not operating in the real world anymore.
And they will say absolutely anything, h